okay we are continuing to look at
pre-release versions of functions in the
function repository preparatory to the
function repository going live hopefully
next week although you can really find
all the stuff on the web
alright so we have this handy function
that is randomly generating entries from
the function repository do I have to
resolve this
hey we got background noise could you
please meet yourself um okay so let's
start off with these here n variational
bound
what's clear why got to do with our
thing well I mean that's just okay fine
okay does this have a seal soda anything
else that is um useful at all I mean
this should surely have see also two
built-in functions
anybody kami
dweeb Danny
yes yeah I mean is there an obvious list
of things what's this that's what that's
a bad link the old story we're getting
rid of this so that's a bad link okay so
we should not link to those we should
link to things in the function
repository that okay yeah I think that's
a I made a utility to auto generate
these definition notebooks from the
standard package functions and what are
we doing with these tutorials which are
probably not completely useless I think
this is the source of a lot of the
examples right like they should just go
in the perspective I know but there's
more stuff here yeah okay I don't know
if we try to sweep all of it into the
function repository this is you know
this is one of those cases where you're
pushing to have it in and it is a
possibly more natural fit for a backlit
repo I do not nobody will use it that
means something so you say but yeah
who's gonna use it though that just as
they haven't used it in the packages
okay so well you have a tutorial though
I mean tutorial is not really
appropriate for single function I
understand that so we need another
mechanism for those yes I mean well we
know perfectly well that we're going to
have to have something which is a way of
aggregating functions here I mean right
so this is one of the one of the things
that should be possible for an
aggregation of functions and then after
all you know all we have to do is to
link once we got a place to put this
tutorial or tech note then we just got
to have those function repository
entries linked to it and then we're
golden
we'll have to have this in any other
structure so you're basically inventing
a halfway measure between function and
and Pacolet repos right now okay if
that's what you want to do I know I'm
not I'm saying that there's a look this
is a level of metadata and possibly this
goes in the notebook archive I mean this
thing could be simply in the notebook
archive as a I don't know what category
it would go into but it's something that
refers to the function repository
because makes it like I want to do that
that does make sense I mean it could be
like a computational essay type thing I
would think so you know and it happens
to have this nice form here I mean this
was very old book type form that we did
this and it's probably not the right way
to do it in modern times all right let's
move on in terms of this random I'll fit
right in with the notebook a character
to have that yeah yeah well so I mean
all we have to do is to point from the
function repository to the notebook
archive I mean the main point is you
know we are counting on the fact that
none of these things is going to rot so
in other words if you point to the note
book archive it's gonna be there it's
gonna be pointing to something
meaningful okay random part choice
choose random parts of an expression
okay it's amusing
okay
our cause degree I'm having a look at
because we've looked at several of that
kind
the date of the Jewish New Year okay
is there any other way to do that
I mean isn't that date next and and this
should isn't that next date of something
, you know calendar Jewish type thing
isn't that right
I look at the source nope that's honest
even if it's someone minor it's still a
nice function and I'm sure I checked
with Nick before I assign this to ego
okay and I think he mentioned that this
is this might be useful so okay alright
but it should certainly link to next
date
could somebody do that I impressively
useful when scheduling our tech
conferences I should say it'd also be
nice if I return the data object and it
should return a date object that's wrong
it should return a date object no
question it should return a date object
I can make that change since the simple
fix
are there any similar functions around
isn't there a Orthodox Eastern Orthodox
Easter yes okay
let's fix those okay graphics bounds
is that in a plot range form
and by the way that's not the right font
there is it if this is a good example of
something that would be extended if it
was tableau yes that is true
I mean honestly this is kind of sloppy
that doesn't that it doesn't I mean does
it work with things poking out and so on
probably not but now this should have in
its author notes something about I mean
either does or doesn't work when things
poke out if you understand what I mean
if I have I guess it probably does work
here it doesn't work with text I bet um
it should also say in here that it uses
the plot range convention right for the
bounce of assuming it does make sense
yeah I'm not sure how its implemented
but we can we can check that okay multi
where it mean definition it's not a very
inspiring example set no but I also know
it's done what it does
you
okay I'm really surprised this isn't a
built-in thing but whatever seems fine
what are we going to do when these
functions become built-in are we just
going to have this page say it's now
built in it's deprecated yep I think
that's all we just been a slag on the
page and we can make it stronger from
search results or something but it'll
still be there and work yeah well I mean
the search results should presumably you
know here's a point about the search
results it should put the function
repository on top but it should have
other search results there as well I
think are we doing that right now
no we shouldn't do that because there
was otherwise when things deprecated
from here people are gonna be like oh my
gosh I'm confused yeah yeah we could
really easily get up just search but
well below including below is the best
would be a good thing to do let's try to
do that can we
Bradlee is that for you I've got that
the easy thing yeah we did this one
yesterday yeah you're not d duped
between the two days multi set inclusion
stop my that's called multi-set
if you have two identical values in the
second set only one in the first it will
give false well okay fine again oh wow
wait a minute when when you say the seal
shows here these are these are function
repository things they shouldn't just be
missing should they I mean if there are
blogs it would look ugly I know but I
think they should be a different color
because what was it going to look like
if we do have two different sections one
for related symbols which is full from
language symbols and this is only see
also yeah maybe we just need a different
header on this section so see also it
should say related functions it does
seem like if there are no related
symbols it looks at a glance that these
are system symbols you're linking checks
though right yeah I think if we came
with the right section so why don't we
say related function repository entries
we could say related resource objects
because I think you can cross linked to
other repositories oh yeah you can look
I think we shall sell in Wolfram
repositories but what's it gonna look
like if it's linking to like the the
data repository it's gonna have
something with a very different style
there because those are multi-word long
multi-word things right it's not gonna
look right I don't think those should be
in the same block cuz I think it'll look
stupid I think this should say we could
put the icons for the repository to the
to the left a little bit
there's different sections to delete
functions but um each other
with a little dingbat to the left of the
line yeah why not there you go that's a
good idea
see also and then that's and then ending
the actual content why don't we say
related items or something something
like that so it doesn't doesn't say
because people are some resources we
call it in the notebook in the
definition of related resources we
should call that here to find related
resources all right how about a color
change and then multi line and I guess
we can we could make them orange like
the repository but that'll be John yeah
do we need a designer to join us here
what what why don't we and we can bring
it up with designing different okay why
don't we teyla fie them I mean that
that's what we're doing elsewhere we're
turning them from the blue to the steel
color when they're external things I
think that's what I would suggest to so
kind of like how standard package links
look in the current documentation right
exactly yes
um and then I agree with you let's let's
put the icon for the repository before
it seems fine to me okay now what are we
calling the one that is a link to the
system functions related symbols okay
that's fine but then this one should
have a related symbols going to I mean
look the fact that these things don't
have related symbols we've seen very few
of those we really should do a parse and
just add a bunch of them not least to
give people examples of what they should
be I think I think it's fine I just just
go dig in just add a bunch ASAP
preferably before we release here um the
cardinality does this define what that
means well it should say what this means
I don't even know what it means it would
be nice to say what it means okay and
you could throw that back to Bob and ask
him to do that just put in something in
details and options it just gives the
definition of multi set cardinality
which I'm not really am understanding
but okay what I'm saying what okay got
some comments on the livestream Brian is
asking her a function moves from
depository to built him will the source
to the function still be available
interesting question um I don't see why
we shouldn't have it as an archived page
but but see that the only thing that
could go wrong there I mean the built-in
will probably a little different than
the thing that's in the repository yeah
it'd probably be very different I'll
probably put a bunch of air-handling and
education right and it will probably be
quite unreadable
unfortunately the code you know once it
becomes production grade code tends to
be rather unrealistic I've the function
repository entry and I think maybe what
that suggests is that the header should
say this is an archived entry and the
function is now you know like like
what's an example of how we where where
there's an obsoleted message in what's
something that's obsoleted i
combinatoric oh so what's an example of
one of those date there was an old date
object we're gonna find that has a
symbol that's weird
what's that doing that seems very wrong
whatever that is it seems wrong Wow
okay I had no idea well cool so pretty
it's not using any of the examples well
what do you know
okay well I don't know where the the
I've never used the stuff that's as bad
I should use this this is cool
um okay
in any case uh there's a banner here
that says it's been obsoleted and I
don't mean we might as well just archive
the rest of the page in that case but we
should make a note that that's what
we're planning to do because we haven't
yet got a pattern of how to obsolete
things here um
Steve on the livestream is saying it's
called function repository but in the
notebook its resource function yeah
try spin show in the cloud it's probably
not gonna work for it well it's been
show something from here let's try it
it's this a totally grotesque in the
cloud I don't think we've there if I
didn't McCloud
it's kind of amusing the fact that it
doesn't have the um that it kind of has
a tidal change in this in that bar is a
bit unfortunate table suggestions the we
could and that would be silly
yeah um okay let's look at that oops
that's not the right cloud um so the
difference between resource function and
function repository is that the
repository is actually our curated
collection of functions but resource
function can also refer to your own that
you have written and cloud deployed to
your oh that's a good point
that's pretty dead that's not very
exciting
I'll cut the show part well that looks
like a bug for the cloud team yeah no
idea what they are sewers though I bet
it's a dynamic I want there I'm sure
it's a dynamic but for some reason it's
not triggering in the cloud although the
cloud has a pretty hard time doing that
but it's going to have to make a server
call every time
okay bit string null space
you
you
you
why is somebody doing it this way that's
just crazy if I might say so force of
habit
it must be very old habit
yeah like 30 years old at least probably
okay well fine zero one null vectors
okay first of all this needs separators
right this is gonna fail the heuristic
for too long a set of examples without
separators right yep I'm sure it's an
Decree list okay okay well I'm not
thrilled with the examples but there's a
similar thing obviously last place with
matrix but where's the matrix the matrix
is given as a set a list of integers
each integer is to be regarded as a row
vector okay if I might say so this
should to say zeros ones I see okay
that's kind of cool actually
okay how about why isn't this pointing
to all those bit functions you know all
the beer X or bit well it should have
bit X or I suppose I'm surprised I
didn't put that in but I guess I didn't
okay let's have it
okay session information that's
music are we sure we don't want to make
that return a data set by default
um I think I made that an argument of it
doesn't seem harmful seems like a
reasonable thing although
I see that's kind of interesting seems
interesting all right let's go generate
the next thing then Don I should do more
than ten here
cows and Cl my gosh why aren't these
built-in well because probably they're
not very good see again it will be
really good to have something which is
an explanation of why these aren't built
in because there's probably something
wrong with them if you if you understand
what I'm saying yes and also this is
related to the poly log function and it
doesn't say that and we really need that
makes sense where traction did you say
poly log
you
you
magnificent okay I thought Zeckendorf
had two F's
partly not
you
nice
okay create resource notebook that
sounds relevant
this is a simple pop right so yeah we
made this before create notebook worked
on function resource I don't think this
should be the of it well it allows us to
get ahead of version releases so we can
you know update this whenever a new
resource type is available as a Pacolet
and then but creating create notebook is
only updated on versions so so if people
in 11.3 can use this because they can't
do create notebook function resource so
this is and then when you should say
this you should say that and by the way
that isn't true anymore
but you should say that so my hair I
mean I think you've got to
um yeah you just you just gotta say why
created definitely you know you got to
explain why it's not the same as create
notebook and you've also got to link to
create notebook make sense yep now in
the case of Claussen CL I mean that's a
case where having a link a backlink from
poly log will be really nice what is the
status of our backlink story
- from built-in to the repository
yes starting to work on that now okay
alright a couple of comments from
livestream Ethan is saying his favorite
resource function is dynamic map yeah
that did seem i if I remember what that
one is let's just take a look at it
Wow McDaniel is something yeah this is a
very useful function I agree
and unfortunately yeah the general
version of this needs to be done for for
just a whole range of functions I mean
this is a this is a more general thing I
mean this is a version of
this would be a good thing to think
about doing um
essentially this is a you know one can
imagine this as a wrapper for many
functions
I mean it's similar to monitor
you
automatically set up the stuff that's
monitoring for you which would be nice
yes except that it has to look inside
the function to be able to do that yeah
but you can make it work for like table
do scan all that stuff no I agree I
agree
Sushma we should add that to the ILB
list if it isn't already there okay umm
also questioned from ello or good
contributions the function repository
going to be highlighted somehow like
community posts we hope so yeah I hope
so
hunting Badgers in the community for
being featured in the function
repository I hope so we know Idid topic
in that first by the way
am i mentioning that in the blog I don't
think I am and I probably should yeah no
to Jessica at a trophy back notebook
mm-hmm um should for banner a link to
the Oh a is entry if it's applicable
yeah why not um I mean it's all a
question of what I mean if people send
these things in then they can get added
you know particularly people send them
in I mean do we have the tools if people
send in the edited source notebook we
have the differing tools to figure out
what's going on don't we
we have something that's okay take it
always no matter all right let's
continue here image split compare oh
that's interesting
huh okay
let me try I mean live a bit dangerously
and try this in the cloud
um murdered I have my cloud notebook up
here there we go
that is being changed right that wording
has been changed yes yes new ones are
already changed still need to go through
and fix all the old ones okay let me see
if this is has even a hope of working
that did not look promising growl okay
so so what are we doing with respect to
that in uh oh my gosh look what just
happened
did you see that yeah that's really
scary well that's a bug cloud bug to be
reported but in terms of testing well
that's cool
yeah that's cool that's very useful um
obviously there are multiple this is
ridiculous this thing going up and down
okay forget that
I hope my next submission is published
its what top Bob I wonder how long shot
Bob and all doesn't make something Bob
over there no that's okay but here look
we got several bugs here so we've got
this absolutely bizarre bug that the
thing is destroyed by copying sounds
very much like one of those quantum
processors so you did copy and not cat
right I did copy I'll try it again just
to prove it to you okay
so let's do this
let's do a copy come on see I guess we
have this record it's the something the
cloud seem to just watch the other if
you just watch it okay
and then it doesn't work now are we
going to put something in here that says
it doesn't work in the cloud we can a
question if it's a cloud notebook bugs
at least and will be fixed at some point
or so it's something that we know isn't
intended to work in cloud because it
uses Java or something then yeah
in the second case we certainly need to
do that and if not that he doesn't
options in somewhere or in the
requirements right in the first case
there so the requirements would say it
needs desktop right yes okay
okay what was the answer to the question
of but by the way do we yet have
examples of Python wrapper functions
here
I think we have a couple in the
submission queue but nothing published
yet okay if I remember correctly check
of a word is a verb in English I assume
might say that's in English -
suggestions say it's in English
Ferrer's diagram didn't we look at this
already
yeah I think you did the local cache
again on that first cell I think that
overrode your the existing information
for charity looked at Oh that's annoying
I shouldn't have done that okay
pop
remove and return an element of an
expression it so mattifies a list in
place in returns it's a super super
obscure example where it says x equals
something which has an X in it and then
you pop X you get Z come on we could
call this list at least yeah
um certainly be better that way but
that's the level of policing that we're
usually not going down to it for the
function repository fair enough
okay I'm not thrilled with this function
I wasn't on the review of it what's here
it's good
well it doesn't suggest that it that it
has a side effect in its name there's
that and there's also the suggestion
that it might be Lisp like with Lisp
like efficiency and in working with
lists
you know emulating linked lists and it's
not any of that
well okay the main issue is would you
expect based on the name that it would
have a side-effect yes if I was thinking
pop is in the list pop push and pop then
I would it has a hopefully short name
there's that's another problem I would I
would prefer something like Lisp pop or
Lisp like pop where who knows
but pop is not a lisp specific
construction there's many anytime you
have a links list datatype and you're
gonna see problem sure I'm not sure it
does but but that might do it might do a
I'm trying to think my history I mean
this was very early 1958 so yeah I mean
it was but I'm a little bit confused
about the relationship between car and
cutter I mean do we have we don't have
car and cutter do we do we not fun no
that's the thing this isn't a linked
list I mean we could do them using Rick
did a really nice some business with
expert bags and we could certainly
emulate them with with what he has I've
done that actually but alright so what
do we want to do with this I hope we
don't have push
as well because push I would not want
that name to be hanging out loud meaning
something like this would would that
make more sense as pop from if it's
editing the list it exerts an in
language convention we use I did yeah
you're right that would be a better name
yeah I don't live stream is suggesting
pop tale but we don't really talk about
tales particularly and then it's
probably some yeah we use rest I guess
and instead of tale right I agree that
pop from is much better than pop and pop
from has the feature that at least it's
you know it's not as likely to get mixed
up with something else
you know you know it's just a sort of
thing we emulate yo in this one of these
wheels getting reinvented constantly and
we always do it with list nesting the
way it's done here it's almost certainly
going to be an insert and or append and
prepend and and and then um you know
whatever equals rest of whatever that's
what it is extract and delete oh that's
just wonderful so it's got all the wrong
efficiency yeah I'm not thrilled well
first thing is pop for okay why don't
you take up this issue is its author but
I think pop from is if it's kind of
survive it should be popped from true
but that's wrong as well remove and
return I mean it should make it clear
that it's a side effect thing look I
think the UM don't make another comment
I mean another thing that we probably
need to tag here is when there is you
know we need to at least know when these
things have side effects I guess any
time as attributes hold first sign that
it might have you know call by whatever
that is reference or some reference self
something like call by right
call-by-name reference we have a much
more bizarre semantics oh yeah there's
an accumulation of call-by-reference
aside from naming conventions do we have
an indicator that for the language no
other go no except that we always
comment on it do we have that comment
for a pen - or auto-increment or
whatever we call + + well okay so
unresearched as to the result so at
least it makes it clear but yeah yeah
yeah bet that that's yeah yeah I mean
mutation make it pretty clear yep I
think pop from is the best we can do
that and I think we should we should
just do that okay challenges data what's
amusing we need some new challenges have
we been adding these other it wasn't
earth happen to that formatting what is
the first one yeah that there's a few
super old notebooks that regenerate I'll
take care of that okay so if I were to
take um if I were to get that so you're
saying here where did I go with that um
let me actually I'm just curious whether
this will work if I go to oh hey I've
got one of these um so is this gonna
require cloud authentication or not H no
I think it'll work without it and just
give you like the publicly available
information where you can get like
profile information if you're glad
connected this is rather slow what is it
doing is it reading some data bin or
something okay that's kind of annoying
what was that
that I'm not sure their specific name or
something that is you know emojis but I
see that here sometimes when there's oh
I think I know what it is like I don't
like emojis learn JSON data or something
it's like URL execute with the broad
JSON format and that doesn't like some
Unicode characters which I know are in
some challenges now so I'll fix that
good why would this not have been picked
up in regression testing here because we
surely we look for messages and the
regression tests well I mean it could be
content that's changed in the actual
data I see okay fine how often are we
running the tests do you know I don't
know okay which team is doing the
testing is it the kernel yeah QA team
yeah okay yeah you know the framework
testing as far as in North you know
daily test runs and testing plan is not
completely hammered out yet but we
definitely need to be running those
regression tests yes yes repeated basis
and we better be running them you know
before we release we better make sure
we've run all the regression tests yep
okay we need to
yeah hopefully at the summer school we
will come up with some more challenges
um okay let's go back over here
file download response change to be
response to prompts the browser to
download as a good'n file name what so
this can be like the result of an API
function so that if you visit it in your
browser it won't show it on in the
window the browser window it'll download
it that's the data file etc I understand
so it's like wrapping it but I don't
understand how this does that you just
use this instead of using HTTP response
and so you can deploy this so what I
don't know yeah right you can deploy
this or it can be the output of an API
function or form function you can have
an API where you ask for a specific file
your code gets the data and right this
is supposed to be something which is
available at the system level something
well go ahead where you really just you
can do it with HTTP response but you
just have to have manually set the
header I understand but the whole point
here is to be able to say I want a
downloadable notebook not a not a cloud
notebook to come out from this URL right
yeah well it's a good function this
should be a built-in thing but I mean
there's nothing wrong I imagine it will
be at some point okay but does sushma
what is our process but for you know
getting these reviewed for being built
in because this one for example should
go to the cloud team to joel and those
guys you don't have a process here but i
can think about it a little bit well I
think I did send that to them at one
point I'm not sure I know there's some
browser just dependencies there are some
that will just reject your headers and
won't work so it's not gonna be
perfectly to our list everywhere
okay well so fine but I mean what do you
think our review process should be so I
mean that's why these author notes will
be useful because then it will say
what's wrong with this thing
term saying so that we have some idea
how difficult it is to actually make it
more system level and robust
I mean it seems to me that there are
there are things here which we should
consider okay there's various states
we're never going to promote it it's
something that
you know we have the framework to
promote it but this is not robust enough
and it's something where it will be
promoted but only as part of some new
framework makes sense
so it seems to me that that it would be
worthwhile for us to maintain at least
internal tagging of what we want to do
with these things with respect to that
so there's an example of something which
probably isn't robust enough you know it
isn't okay actually they're two initial
states one is one is that the design is
not fine good enough and the other is
they implement there's some problem with
the implementation I mean well I guess
essentially none of these
implementations are going to be good
enough yeah they need a lot more work
but this is the type of thing that
should probably if it gets put in the
system it should just be built in as
HTTP response functionality yes it
probably should be right but so even
that note even the author note saying
saying that would be useful because then
once we look at it we say what's going
on with this oh you look at the author
note it says this isn't you know this
doesn't work in all browsers and it
should one day be part of HTTP response
that will be very useful to have and I
don't see any reason not to expose that
to the world
make sense to people
yeah okay so let's put that author note
in here and then it will get exposed
although when I made this I wasn't aware
of the fact it wouldn't work in all
browsers okay
well that's some I mean it probably it
matter what popular ones that are
running on chromium there's probably not
gonna work and I mean that's something
to determine right it's not right you
know even the statement we don't know if
it works and all of them is a reasonable
thing to put there because what's
happening here you know this is
something where somebody can come back
from the community for example and say
yes it does work or know here's a fix or
whatever else
from camelcase okay fine
that is really weird you can't do that
yeah a symbol as an option that should
be rejected can't do that that should be
automatically rejected who is paying
attention to what the automatic word you
know what what these um Rick is that for
you or is that somebody else now who's
going to add these those kinds of rules
we ever wrestled that now if this was
submitted today it would have been
caught but this is this is a thing that
we manually look for like automatically
identifying I guess we could just
identify options just look at options of
this thing look this is going to this is
easy I mean you know what we would be
one thing to do here is to say I mean we
were already it will already be shocking
at this level right if we say options of
this thing there you go this is bad but
there's a I have to figure out a list of
what symbols should or shouldn't be
right you could just see if they have
definitions if down values our own
values sir then you've and flag it know
Wolfram language data will tell you
whether it's an option Oh will it be
really useful if it doesn't it should
but I'm pretty sure it does names
options taken by the symbol well it
should tell you if not I could just
generate a list of known symbols used as
options exactly if it's not Elvis just
have it as a suggestion saying you sure
you meant use this and looks like to
lowercase is a built-in function okay I
throw me okay Brett you could have
strange eyes dit and it's okay but
having said upon frowned upon but that
it's iffy but okay yeah yeah but the
symbolist yeah this should have been
this needs to be updated her okay fine
sorry
so let's let's sum so then I think we
just say quotes lower case after this
and quotes up a case after this to
the lowercase form the uppercase form or
whatever however you want to do it but
that this needs to be fixed
okay um some comments on this live
stream
[Music]
it's funny okay um resource function
of resource submissions let's take a
look there that's one of mine does it
not work first time I tried it was
you'll be on the company yeah so you get
a bunch of stuff from other repositories
no one else should see any of that
because you're on the company publisher
ID other people just get something like
this but probably only with two or three
yeah since you're sharing a publisher ID
with a bunch of internal people you get
a bunch okay
there's Bob over here too no no no
somebody there's a function called Bob
yeah okay why can't I click on something
to actually see the submission notebook
here there's that whole suite of
internal tools that aren't for this
meeting okay fine okay um yeah d8 is
saying from current cases useful I also
want a string spluttered yeah well you
can either use string split or it's
possible we should have a function that
says um you know I mean camel casing is
a d camel casing is a mess I wouldn't
make it an option yeah
because I think the use cases are
different but but camel casing is true
Liam a D camel casing is a heuristic
mess which is why it's not built-in we
tried to do this as a built-in thing but
it's full of you know weird just so and
so names and so on um see this is a
general comment but I'll look at it
about I can eyes um oops what on earth
is this okay I see Oh what happened here
what happens here this didn't okay so
the basic point is plot
sign X tab sign X this is a good point
there's an interesting point um
x10 or something aligned whatever
okay now let's icon eyes this
I don't think we thought of this issue
and then we uh nyah knives that well
that worked okay but if we ionize the
whole thing
and then we are like kanai's doesn't
okay I that's a very good point not
thought about that I this is not the
right meeting to discuss that but Sushma
if you can feed that I guess - John yes
I know right it's a good point
Wow Sandler is getting something about
to expression invalid syntax before
doctype whatever
see the problem of these things is
always you know these are not going to
be as good these functions are not going
to be as good but I don't know exactly
what that's happening with the
challengers side perhaps um
do you think it makes sense dad
functions are the sample applications in
or let's in the repo we are ahead of you
on that
yes that is actually where are those
examples where are those things where
are the negative ones Megan is working
on yes I don't think she's done it yet
what do you mean she's well she's trying
to like make large class single
functions that handle classes of things
I don't know I'm not sure okay but I
mean the basic idea there is that in the
neural net repository there are often
packaging and deep packaging functions
that are quite complicated and we're
trying to put those in the function
repository even though which will make
the examples much cleaner even though
those functions are pretty obscure
because they are you know packaged this
data for use in this weird neuron that
Bob didn't you submit one like that hey
yeah I have one that we're keeping his
provisional because I think it might be
superseded by Megan's but we can
certainly look at it what what does it
mean provisional what are you talking
about and we have this provisional
status for things that but all they that
that means they have they work they work
but they're not shown on any of the
pages they're not in the search results
yeah they have a stripe Wow yeah okay
know about it you can use it but if you
know that you can use it yeah sometimes
you do this for things that require
future functionality then you're like
twelve one or then really speculate or
something okay
so this kind of function the digit
colorization yeah I I made this made
this that Megan said I think we can do a
bunch of I'm sorry provisional made
provisional so that we have one that's
not neural net based I thought it wasn't
her on that based now I would check that
but but it doesn't really matter but
this this shows the example shows the
principal and that's what I think call
is looking for there
Keeks askew the argument failed i said
'you should tell us what you know i
think he's doing that research
submission that worked for you it's not
working for him uh okay well that's
something for a sample permissions bug
in my code or something yes okay let's
keep going here
chaos game we actually had looked at
because of the generalized Chaos game
cell information didn't we already look
at that yeah we did okay desaturate
except we looked at that Astro distance
is new I mean since we haven't looked at
it yet that's kind of cool
that's cool I mean we'll eventually have
this as a built-in thing but that's nice
to see why is it so fuzzy here
we are working on that yeah I actually
have a branch that sells a lot of that
stuff okay so if I say here Mars - I'm
just checking that this works
fatal juice if I know how to spell it
you
oh very cool hmm that's really cool
well okay fine I mean that's go on
playing I have no idea what any of these
things are
ha why do you know I guess Sirius is
close to us
I don't know battle just was so far away
okay nice
multivariate trimming I think that's in
that same family as those other things
helped when not the opposite of when
you know there's a certain okay yep test
to a file exists fair enough I don't
think I need to look at that and think I
understand what that's doing boy okay we
got in the tally collection here list
input field make multiple input fields
that update elements in the same list
I don't even understand that oh I see
this is good for constructing forms I
guess like yep custom ones okay let's
keep going
closed cell groups it's kind of
interesting
that's kind of interesting so for
example if I go here
I didn't know we only picked up in those
things I see I see that's the way it has
to work
who what just happened that why didn't
that close all my cell groups it has a
set of defaults that are I think like
title now like section subsection I
Cameron trusts up my head but you can
tell it certain styles if you want to
override that
yeah I didn't generalize it that much I
mean I still have that one yeah
um you just throw a section in somewhere
you'll see well I'll just say input cool
that's
cool and there's an open cell groups if
you want to get them back where o of the
function yeah well now I just wanted to
see it that's very cool what what is the
return value here it's just a cell
objects of what it found enclosed and it
it's a nice function he buried the
snails there yeah isn't this is nice
okay and limit patent old old function
which has been almost in the system for
like 25 years
yeah
okay another multivariate weird thing
this before
you
you
you
why isn't this called I mean why is it
called partition not
petition or whatever
Danny I don't know offhand well I I
don't think this is harmful yeah I mean
it's one of these to me obscure
combinatoric or related functions okay
Monge poor mr. Monge he's been reduced
to a single of eponymous function
is that really the only meaningful I
mean why is it called Monge point here
when
there probably should have been named
monster than Monge well and the six mid
plains apparently so for some reason
this this doesn't seem right to me that
would be a heck of a music group Mons
point in the six mid plains a jazz jazz
septet I have their first LP on vinyl um
okay
I'm not surprised Rick um so first of
all does it actually take a tetrahedron
it should I mean it would be why don't
we tell Edie that why don't we ask him
to change this what what should it do at
least
very weird that it well look it's one of
these things where it's a fairly
specialized thing and you probably do
want both cases all the time I think it
more it would more naturally return a an
association um-hmm Karl points out that
Wikipedia there's lots of Monge related
things yes I I think this is not a
winner I think it should say Monge point
yes it should somehow have a separate
wage should have a second argument that
allows it to return the hyperplanes we
could call it Marge point and Plains or
you could have LeMans points and I'm on
hyperplanes separate functions
well I got involved in computing it it's
probably all the same computation we
might as well just do it in one go oh my
information launch data that's a little
weird um actually it's not
those are independently computed it
should be two separate functions launch
points and launch hyper planes and do
you think mid planes should be a
spelling word what does that phrase mean
I'm non familiar why as soon as the
equivalent of a midpoint
it's the mid plane in 3d between two
points I would assume okay um okay so
first point is can you report that
sushma or I can send it into spelling no
I can do that why don't you do it and
ask them if they agree second point I
think this should be broken into March
points and ones planes okay okay so can
that be sent back to Ed for four yep
what the heck is this
that's is contributed by me
oh it probably came out of Summit and KS
oh yeah it's it's filled the head
positions for Turing machines
I contributed it doesn't mean it's right
did somebody look at this
it looks reasonable actually okay
Japanese text tokenizer my gosh wow
that's cool Wow okay whose is this
that's my thing that has to be Rick
ya know you were into Japanese then
that's probably a lot I don't know he's
been turning Japanese since the talking
heads came out with the idea again a
reference to popular culture that I
can't I got that one I'm sure you have
that on vinyl
now I actually don't have any vinyl okay
find the inflection points a function of
one variable
we looked at this last time there was a
packet issue that I needed to correct
okay all right let's keep going a bit
let's have a by the way why is my okay
pity we messed up that you Nika fire
because I'm surprised that we've had as
many birthdays so to speak as some of
seeing things a second time
amusing
harmless amusing
that's nice
sort of related to the that maximum
values one of that was is you should we
should link those we should link those
magic square other than
but a good idea but this is a random
magic square isn't it
what an earth is this is it a random
magic scrap let's find out I am totally
confused help me out mathematically is
it not the case that there's just a huge
number of magic squares of a given size
I have no idea but for 3x3 they might
all be close relatives if there's a
canonicalization what's the
implementation code for it yeah and also
by the way this example yeah but by the
way this this hasn't needs more
separators in it
this is grotesque and pointless in my
opinion
that's just really I mean I just don't
understand why that has to be so
if you're gonna do that at least you
know do the courtesy of ionizing the
thing um again we are we gonna give
these pieces of feedback to the authors
or how's this working session is just
gonna fix everything no these are the
things that Enriquez submitted from
demonstrations and I do see that we need
to change the contributed by to say
would from staff based on you know so
instead of person but I can send it to
end okay yeah I mean just look yeah this
is no good
I mean basically these examples anytime
there's an example that's more than
about two lines long you got to be
suspicious I mean I would have hoped
that he could do better than that in
February of this year when we've already
had all these things to find okay
separate as a wrong example is crazy
plus if this is a random magic square
then please let's call it random magic
square and let's randomize it the code
for that what the heck
okay definitely not random this must
have come the code must have been taken
right out of the demonstration though I
would think this seems like a sloppy job
let's when we asked Eric Weiss you know
somebody what the story is with this you
would know instantly okay also it looks
like looks like yeah not very exciting
code I mean it's good functionality we
definitely want something does but I
think ran a magic square seems to make
more sense to me unless it's unless
there's a good reason to not do that it
might be tricky to generate them at
random I'll say that it might be yes and
who knows what the measure is so that
might not be possible so so if that
means then that the documentation should
say it is a magic square
sighs whatever right which is perfectly
okay I mean it's just like we get um
it's a question to bring up Tara kill he
will know that looks like an aerial
photograph of some random piece of brush
land oh that's a work of beauty it's
kind of interesting
okay I get a lot of use out of these
guys gals whatever fair enough
cool don't we want to say anything about
genomes in here I mean does this work on
anything other than it is intended for
genomes I've adapted them for text but
but not here I've got it not in this
function it is it is strictly genome
based okay well that's cool and I hope
we can link that from I mean does this
why doesn't know it does link to genome
data that's good could probably also
link to faster the file format true
position largest we really don't
otherwise have this has no contributor
might come from me but maybe not isn't
this the sample
oh it could be is it is it right I mean
is it is it it seems reasonable
okay I think this one was deliberately
kept simple soap used as a simple trace
loading this is useful I use this all
the time for debugging initialization
things like that is that the right
phrase trace loading or should it be
called monitor loading or an event I see
okay maybe should be traced print
loading hmm traced loading print I don't
think so it doesn't trace loading is
fine
yeah a lot of nice things in here this
isn't good
okay largest prime factor easy but
useful
and arguably that should be a built-in
thing
it's sort of a one-liner though reverse
sort is a one-liner but that's built-in
yeah actually it's not a one-liner
because really it's implemented
tiebreaking yeah the tiebreaking exactly
okay this is nice this is a weird one
why is Ed incapable of making the first
example simple come on come on come on
come on
no no crazy look what does he mean
symbol anyway but but what is this okay
so there's something wrong here a little
bit ornate great great okay what is the
graphics 30 I think you need there's
three dimensions okay this is bad okay
come on we can do better than this right
so why why isn't there one of these
there's supposed to be one of these what
the heck is this comma quotes 2d it says
dimension there no buzzes buzz come on
this this needs to be done better first
of all this should be broken into two
functions it should be um oh my god oh
my god it's not even a poly is it a
polygon um
polygon and poly tope maybe well just 3d
after it but what is it it's sure it's
not a symbol it has nothing to do with a
symbol right now
but this is really annoyingly bad if I
might say so I mean that's a really dumb
idea to do it that way
okay well the functionality is nice I
mean I would have thought this should be
you know it's more like text to polygons
isn't it doesn't discretize graphics
essentially do this as well yeah but
this is probably producing an actual
polygon and I think this should be
called text to polygons and it should be
text to polygons and text to polygon 3d
okay and although it isn't always text
you can put an arbitrary expression in
there well I don't know how arbitrary it
is you know and what happens if I put X
cubed over 1 plus X in there okay well
that's because it's a function
repository function not a built-in well
it should be clarified in the
documentation what kinds of expressions
it accepts well like text might be what
it accepts absolutely so yes I yeah okay
I mean and I mean it maybe as a courtesy
it's accepting these but okay this this
let's get this fixed please okay yes
Matalin and that's a shockingly bad
first example yep I mean shockingly
ridiculous and again we should have a
heuristic for routing those out and it's
or innate I I can add something for that
that'll be pretty simple heuristic I
think fine I reckon the first example so
let me make us a heuristic suggestion if
the first example isn't apply the
function to a thing and get there is
with possibly some rappers like graphics
around it then it's bad sign yeah that'd
be suspicious
when 32 windows talk to what's not gonna
work for a while on my machine this one
does have platform checking built-in
though yeah it's a graceful failure as I
recall it doesn't it stops short of
reformat in your drive ok it does do the
RM minus RF but right ok oh these were
nice throbbed Akbar splines
contributions is it consistent with our
other spline functionality I I believe
so it doesn't not positive doesn't refer
to it it should the symbols for splines
here you know here's another heuristic
that we could consider is if you do a
search if you look at the name of one of
the submitted functions here you do a
search in the built-in functions and you
find something with an overlapping name
at least flag that
I've been working on something a
resource function that can auto suggest
keywords and symbols that are related
resources that's a very good idea
eventually I'd like to have it built in
he'll come to me there's tons of stuff
here right spline shouldn't you have a
resource function that writes resource
functions before you build one that
rewrites them I do have that actually I
have the suspicious of that are you
trying to think is Jeff Lee sorry okay
that's amusing nice I wonder are these
actually correct colorblindness
yeah that's a perfectly form seven sorry
there's anybody on this cold red-green
color blind can they tell because I
don't think this is right because I
think you have to have the same we got a
coke somebody I I don't think this is
right because if you specify both colors
you see what I'm saying you've got to
conform the colors to the same gray
level am I making sense
otherwise it's trivial to tell could
whoever's causing us to echo please flip
themselves on you
if I take this and I say color convert
grayscale know if this is hopeless this
not gonna work
come on send that back to ed you've got
to take
second color did you understand what I'm
saying and get it so it's the same I
don't know what it is luminance or
something no that's what you do is you
take that first color and you maybe turn
it into HSB or something and then you
just change the hue in the direction of
that second color but not the you get
what I'm saying
yeah I mean you're saying the examples
need to be changed no I'm saying the
function needs to be changed
I know what you're talking about I could
I could either except myself forward a
tone okay okay
what happens if you just do you know
darker green or or lighter red
presumably well let's try it
come closer it'll come closer but it
won't be right because unless it's the
unless it's the same I mean I don't I
think probably maybe you need to use XYZ
chromaticity or something I'm not
completely sure I know I'm sorry I don't
know enough about this what's his name
Sam yeah okay so that's that's close
that it's closer it's closer yeah but
it's not right shouldn't have to know
the colors that will work correctly of
course I'm also in a you know just why
why the first example here don't use
something that has extra complexity in
it I mean I don't know how to detect
that but obviously we don't want to use
something with extra complexity this
could just have a one argument version
that just defaults to red-green yeah
would be a good idea what the heck is
this you don't say
ed but that's the wrong point to be
making well maybe the point here isn't
to make one that is it's a colored line
and I don't know what yeah and it's not
really a colorblindness diagram it's a
it's a color blindness test I think I
think ed may want to clarify what
exactly he was intending and and all
that okay the examples better this is
mine okay
any objections
this one
I think this one is pretty
non-controversial has the N determinant
again doesn't look controversial to me
okay you know what put a separator line
here come on yep
oops which one was that echo timing
I fell timing Oh
you
harmless
fine and homeless although doesn't it
not it's it's not linking to oh I see it
does link to other equations great from
atomic number that's just element data
of the number wait a second that's not
the right thing to call this because
from atomic numbers suggests that it's
the it says find the element but that's
not right find the element string find
the element symbol for a given metallic
number right see what I'm saying yeah
it's I arguably a shorthand finding the
element would imply an entity right yeah
I would imply the entity which this is
not doing that's right okay look if I
say element data of 17 I will get the I
hope I'll get what do I get I get the
entity chlorine right okay so yeah
finite element strain yeah it would be
element symbol symbol okay
as a string
otherwise no objection so echo timing
did final publishing step was never
taken I don't have someone on the
content team that's why but it's Rick's
function is finding it but no one else
would be able to find it
so I might still have some issue that
needs to be cleared okay so you're
telling me that if I look good okay by
the way space weather there is this
calling an external API I mean
presumably we don't measure the space
weather ourselves I kind of need a
satellite to do that okay is it decently
fast
let's see how space weather wow that's
nice
that's pretty cool
you know maybe we should have a function
tells us the number of sunspots
since we have sunrise sunset and so on
we could just have sunspot count
I know it's really sunspot number
monthly sunspot number said person
what's that it's our son the one yes the
one the year I was a very heliocentric
of a function you know what
Wow the zero sunspots today that's
really wild it should be noted that and
it says this and the details and options
that sunspot number is not exactly the
same thing as the number of sunspots
you'd expect to see when looking at the
Sun and that's not something the Jeff
did that's just a standard that's out
there
what is it if it isn't the
you see when looking at the site I don't
know it's some proportional thing but
it's not exactly a proportionality I
don't really know that's weird
I always thought that these plots by the
way minor thing but you might ask Jeff
my doesn't you put a dateless plot
around this seems no reason not to do
that
yep
that's pretty cool
you
I like I mean it's kind of weird
assayer but why not um that's cool
it's a cool function I mean I would have
a slight if we care about sunspots the
I feel like sunspots are not obvious
that space weather would give you
sunspots and I would argue that we could
have a function called sunspots sunspot
count
you
Sanders pointed out that I'm wrong about
at the time it does show answers I see
no problems with it so I feel like we
should publish it okay do you want to
just do it
I can find it yep
um what is this this is your this is
just the formatting wrapper yeah and
we're gonna be adding that as my default
behavior for the main symbol but this is
still be relevant first stuff that right
people know will get returned
this is pretty long
tooth I mean this certificate was done
for version one long before we had
really structured data are we sure this
is the right way
oh boy so this is calling another
function to get the Prime certificates
well it's kind of interesting I've not
seen that in any of these so we're
choosing to use the resource function
form here rather than the function blob
right yeah and I have mentioned that's
necessary when riding when altering two
things at the same time but we felt
reformatted in fact I suppose although
we do have that that branch for
replacing the boxes and I think we're
looking at auto updating those as well
right yeah yeah so this probably should
should use function blobs here but this
is an interest in case of an independent
interdependent function repository
entries yeah you would author it that
way you would want to refer to it by
name but we would clean up the examples
automatically this feeds right into one
of those selfies you talked about in
Europe coming blog yeah does anybody
know whether this is sensible I mean if
we were doing this today will be before
Matt these certificates in the same way
will be have them as associations and
who knows what else
anybody know I do not go off hand should
we ask Charles or somebody Charles will
adore Erik any of those people now
Charles probably would
the other two might I'm not sure but
let's just ask them I mean given that
we're doing this we might as well it's
not obviously silly but I mean it might
be that in the last 30 years
might be a better way to do it
my lawn would probably know to to the
skim do we even mention this discount
from his his stuff are we sure it did it
may have been stuff that was done
somewhat later okay
how big
I'm just curious my own curiosity here
if I take
does this get baked or what is it - okay
this is utterly incomprehensible to me
what this is doing
I mean this is interesting because it's
a proof just like find equational proof
gives a proof
okay let's live a bit more dangerously
here I mean it's it's one it's another
example of one of our proof type outputs
yeah it's at least fast
what the heck is it doing you have any
idea
no okay
I would I would venture to guess that no
I shouldn't say I don't know
you
okay well it's interesting all right
did you publish ICO timing yes maybe the
left margins on those actual things are
being presented incorrectly on the web
which is very widely rolling off
you mean these echo timing yeah I think
looks like a useful function it is
really why does why is the label first
is that the way that echo works it's the
other way around yeah cuz that's this
was this is wrong it should be fixed can
you fix it I mean the fact is that the
reason I know why this happened this is
because originally when we were
designing echo is going to be the other
way around
entirely no it went back and fixed this
one yeah we can fix that okay and I
think you should also call an expert all
and body you're gonna do that fix seems
quite useful why does it have to say
echo timing I mean isn't that rather
ugly oh I see that's why isn't it giving
something about well whatever I it's
okay yeah typically you would put it in
the body of your I understand that but I
mean echo just has the single greater
than greater than um it'd be nice if the
label is the hold form of what you're
evaluating I'm sure in death um sorry
again so if the the label if you don't
tell it explicitly what to use show the
the hold form like of what you're about
to be that could be big I mean I would
prefer to look in a perfect world if
this was a built-in system thing what I
would do is to have a little tiny [ __ ] I
call and then a greater than greater
than or it could be a mechanized input
that way you can open it to see like
what the head is and get the whole thing
if you want how why do you believe that
the thing isn't gonna blow itself up
when you put it in there it has to be
the held like a nice thing right yeah
I've done a bunch of an evaluated a
canister I know how to make that work
well that would be a nice default put
them what you think is right
um
okay toured to try one more I I need to
go in a moment but but um ah
Seth is observing that um this is a this
an interesting compliment to the opening
of Wolfram engine yes not unnoticed um
it is in theory part of a master plan
um I very quick look here resource
function message for the people on the
livestream who are looking to submit
resource functions take note of this one
it's very useful for that should we
mention this in the blog this would be a
good subtlety to mention the blast yeah
okay hold on let me just put an put a
note in here so that I remember to do
that or or could somebody send this to
Jessica for their feedback notebook and
I'll be looking at that in about two
hours
um has an awful lot of text - oh it's a
complicated issue right yeah it's
loosely explaining the same stuff their
message does seemed worth having it in
there though so you don't look at two
pages this is this in fact what a
spirograph does and I I hate to ask the
question but is that is a spirograph for
trademark
that's somehow thought we considered
that but I can't remember for sure
I'm sure we did isn't it
didn't this come out of a demonstration
okay that's that's when I think we
considered it way back when yeah but I'm
not positive that we did no it's fine I
think we can assume this is okay um well
I'm concerned that maybe we assumed it
back then and then sure enough I don't
know memory isn't good enough on this I
would have thought but that could be a
much less obscure function but this is
beautiful that's it all fine we're
hearing a lot of typing effective
precision what the heck is that it tries
to deduce the precision of the
mathematical precision of an expression
so it only goes inside math functions if
you have something like X what is
precision do facts of 1x of 1.0 it'll
give you machine precision really pretty
sure huh it's kind of crazy
those are obviously wrong actually it's
not obviously wrong agreed right which
is why we want the effect of precision
function around fine it's something
we've used internally since forever
fair enough font color from background
color for our web developers out there
it just tells you what issues black or
white huh
I understand it has a very weird name
for that um it could just be contrasting
font color
yes that would seem better since you
don't there's no
it's background and it's just cotton
you're right contrasting font color
it seems like a pretty defensive name
though I don't know it only picks black
or white like that name seems that could
be used or like a complementary type of
color selection which one contrast in
color oh yeah I mean aspire to people on
our live stream are pointing out that
spirograph is trademarked okay I was
just about to say the same okay - can we
can we make a note please deal with that
yep
I don't know where we say that on the
page where will we say that on the page
we have an idea how that's gonna work
I took me just indicate that with a
trademark and put it in the details and
options probably
to people
I have no idea what our way of handling
this is that's what seems to me to make
sense yeah check with Eric you said yeah
it may be sufficient to just make a note
in the details and options that says
spirograph is a trademark mark yeah all
whoever it's a trademark of Hasbro I
think it's okay
I think it'd still be very difficult for
us to put a TM there without it
messing up I mean we might be able to
say plot a spirograph it's not plotting
ass pirate what is a spirograph I mean
it it's there's a spirograph set with a
bunch of wheels in it I would have
thought this should be called spirograph
plot or something I think that would
make a lot more sense to call this
paragraph plot yeah it really would make
more sense to say that although whether
this is anything to do with the
spirograph kit I don't know I mean
there's a lot of this is a very you know
complex number wheels kind of thing
anyway spirograph plot fix the trademark
stuff and we should be good with this
um so font color from background color
we're gonna leave is that right
not
guys think it's fine we could probably
sit in for half an hour and come up with
the perfect name but it's fine
see useful function alright
I don't like its name very much right I
don't love its name but um
whatever it's okay it's not like
squatting on a name that's gonna be for
something else so that's fine the
spirograph demonstration very explicitly
says it's trademarked just so people
know okay so that was a goof up so we
shouldn't have made that mistake right
we should understand how that mistake
got made
none of us start to check myself
included okay
something for the checklist um and
there's a good good thing we could do we
could have something that goes how would
you tell other than going to look at the
big PTO database of whether something is
a trademark term be a good function to
have I think it's hard I mean isn't that
what what's that company called oh gosh
very famous company that has the PTO
database
oh I've forgotten completely um there's
some whole company I think that who's
whose world is about doing trademark
searches um maybe it's part of Thomson
Reuters now who knows okay
string intersection queue this one
confused me
expected this to be two strings that
they do the strings themselves intersect
not do they have characters that
intersect
know what I'm saying yeah but if they
have any characters in common then they
intersect I understand it but I'm saying
strings intersecting it's like hello and
lower they intersect because the L oh
right well what you want I think is a
third argument that says how the minimal
intersection size to accept no no no but
I'm saying that you weren't overlapping
yeah but I mean if there's characters in
common then there's an overlap of one
minimum why don't you just call it
common characters cue that that would
have been better I guess maybe we should
just change it since we can still I
think the better function would be to
have a minimal overlap though as a
specification that has are now putting a
whole suite of these with this prefix
string well let's talk to him so what
you're suggesting in this case is that
there's an N there which says that that
the engrams it's it's testing common
Engram yo it just doesn't have the right
name intersecting is not the right name
I don't think
because intersecting is not intersect
Sean well it's that's a bad claim um I
think he made a string intersection that
gives the common characters that's right
yeah intersecting Q this is not bad for
a name I just think the functionality
itself could be slightly enhanced well
but this does what I expect it's right
okay okay okay okay my linked strings
aren't popular
oh no but that would be a great
different function linked strings cue
fair enough
don't think it's the most popular
function in the world but it's kind of
amusing I'd rather have linked strings
that makes um well that that's a
question of finding it's like those
games where you supposed to you know
give a word then you find a word that
starts with the letter that the previous
word ends with and so on right sure we
have some challenges related to that
okay gray code this is okay it's it's a
pity that it's not really the gray code
there's many gray codes the layout of
the examples here is sort of all we had
this idea of having showing me a
resource object always in there early on
oh that's a little yeah this is made in
the very very old template notebook and
these are automatically converted which
they can be improved it will be nice if
the date if it mentioned the details and
options so this is just a gray code
there it's not unique
I could add that
huran they no they're not there's
multiple ways to do it look it up that's
me it's obviously there are multiple
ways because you could just rotate the
the digits right because the only
problem now to have one property the
Hamming distance of one or something
like as you go yeah exactly
speaking of Greg you were graying out on
me for a moment there
what oh really okay context maybe I need
to go soon but let's just get through
this batch and then we wrap um context
module okay
sophisticated but sensible append
sequence
it's amusing
yeah this is a useful thing I have
wanted this many times except that
that's crazy
right isn't it I mean I see it counts
from the left fair enough can we please
put separators in here please that's all
of these are in the list we are going
through them one by one yes okay
you
don't we already have this isn't this
name something different that we have
this I mean this is the this is the a
log of pad left which by the way we
should mention here paddle F is the this
pad left already do this maybe but
nobody would know it oh no cause it
takes everything to have common maximum
length I guess yes right the whole case
wouldn't do that right okay I mean this
is again one that could be thought of as
a possible system thing
it's a Christopher function
what does it import it to
okay as soon as useful I don't know how
unreal you would be if you just remove
this semicolon on the first example
pretty unreal I would guess it's pretty
seriously unwieldy
I mean I think if you look at this thing
yeah I'm a planet yeah clearly I wonder
whether I mean in a perfect world maybe
it should be able to have another piece
in it mail these probably don't want
that there's probably some helper
function here that does this thing to be
able to plot that piece oh it's a
researcher you know what we're going to
have a whole bunch of stuff that builds
on this that is part of the geo graph
functionality so let's not let's not
worry about this yet this is very nice
to have something that does this okay
and Fourier cause transform
you
fine tetrahedral edge angles really we
don't have this as a built-in thing now
you
and do not know solid angle yeah I would
think so we might but but but but I mean
returns the angles opposite the edges I
see this is a tetrahedron specified in
some totally wacky way I didn't know you
could do that I can Silvius you can do
that yeah you just specify
I see so I see I see I see I see I see
this is a disembodied tetrahedron right
these are all concrete tetrahedra
sitting in space so I'm saying with
specific coordinates for their corners
there's a disembodied tetrahedron which
just has edge lengths so it's tumbling
where in whatever way it wants to but
that's an interesting case with respect
to our geometry system because we can
have a um I don't even know how you do
that for a triangle I mean if I say
triangle three four five for example
what do i get if i say graphics of that
oh dear
what am i supposed to get two triangle
wants vertices it's the disembodied
versus absolute
semi-abstract we do we have a way of
specifying a triangle by the three edge
lines yes we have SSS triangle okay
that's what we want so we it would be
the equivalent for a tetrahedron that
we're dealing with here yeah right
I wonder if there is an sss I mean there
isn't that would be a nice function to I
guess it's a worthwhile function to have
there might be the sort of seeing the
geometry not not the Alpha related
geometry stuff you know Dan McDonald and
others they haven't done 3d yet I say
Tony in 2d yeah I would be something
they'd pick up if they do 3d know we
could have a thing called side specified
no SSSs SSSs tetrahedron I don't think
so um abstract tetrahedron or something
a suggestion by the way maybe in the
community group for the function
repository we should have a some
organized suggestions list because
something like that it's obviously not
particularly hard to implement
but there may be people who suggest
things who are not about to implement
them and that would be useful so I don't
know how that community group is being
organized but that's some um ah you know
okay oh yeah we're we're way over time
let's just have a quick look down here
this is addictive you know this is the
problem graphics - we really looked at
this one we already looked at mala
Sushma as a right curly bracket on this
last one is wrong
it's italics we need to fix it oh yeah
okay monitor test report that's cool
Wow that's another reproduction yeah
it's something I use all the time
output oh yeah I know it's cousin that I
can fix it
yeah but also this is a candidate for
being a built-in thing what why enough
isn't this a built-in thing
that that will be something to feed to
Raj if he's ever seen this has he seen
it do you know I don't think so but I
can send it to him as seems to they're
mine is it sensible
you
it's okay ah
this needs separated lines on it I think
those didn't exist and also we don't
need to put you know the place where the
printing press wasn't for that let's not
do that just point it to the online
version hopefully that does point to the
online version and that is something I
told them to do but I could just have
them because citation you know you just
grabbed it from the old material yes I
mean they started doing it from the damn
thing some demonstrations or something I
think it's silly I think we should
consider the online version to be
canonical I could I mean we could just
have it like as external link and then I
think source metadata is good it's just
you don't need the this is very
old-school I mean this is very much like
you know giving a citation like this
with a publisher name and so on and I
just wouldn't bother I would just say
you know this thing by the way it lacks
an author name not that I particularly
mind but but given the publisher name it
would seem like you should put the
author name as well yes that was brought
to attention today and I said we should
put out the name okay then I recommend
we have the author name the title in
italics by the way and then just um the
page numbers they um yes I I see Bradley
has to leave and he sent a bird say to
say it everybody needs to have that term
you know it's interesting that I you
know I do find myself typing is resource
function let me just check something
here in the autocomplete er has it been
properly promoted no it absolutely
hasn't
that will be a good thing to do Rick had
an interesting function a long time ago
with I registered a key keyboard
shortcut for resource function similar
to control equal he's talking about that
just the similar resource function that
yeah I'm just talking about if you were
to type resource function that's a
really bad set of well I it seems to be
in promoted that's probably cuz I typed
it it should default to the top my
response form is surely not the top of
this um by the way you did notes he my
note about wolfie say yes and hopefully
we'll get the designer sense for the
yeah Billy can provide the perfect wolf
um real text string that was a very
early one wasn't it no it was actually
somebody had requested this on community
this kind of function and I thought I
would just add it to the repo okay
I have only one objection I think the
name of the variable should be X naught
n since it's a real number not an
integer
my suggestion assertion where you make a
note of that for me yep thanks I think
that should be Penrose tile
Pano's tile itself is a different thing
you
is that anybody agree disagree
I agree I think in general it's a good
rule of thumb if you making graphics
should probably add plot to it yeah
okay all right we better wrap up
addictive though this is um I feel you
know I'm a little concerned about all
the things we haven't looked at because
I'm seeing that we are finding issues in
about one out of three I think of these
now I mean I guess we can continue to
fix them there's no harm in that
and if we wanted to update a Penrose
tile to Penrose tiles I guess we could
pretty much silently do that so long as
the Penrose tile previous pano style
function redirects to the new one right
right we have a called alias name thing
in place okay good all right well um
okay I may need to contact some people
this evening if I have questions for the
blog and all but Jessica will deal with
that um as needed all right well thanks
all this is looking really nice and
thanks to folks on the livestream for
their comments and talk you'll soon
birds say that